[Music]
all right hey everybody welcome back 6
42 happy monday to you it is time for
mondays with monica and
as everybody knows the pandemic has
touched so many parts of our lives and
our economy
and that's especially true for the world
famous live entertainment
that we all know and love here in las
vegas joining me to discuss the future
of live shows is writer actor comedian
and former strip headliner
mr george wallace george you're actually
on the air what are you doing
i'm telling you which should wear with
my my glasses on my mask you know
because i'm talking about
talking to you you can put both of them
on george if you want it's up to you
hey good morning monica good morning to
you listen let me tell you something
i've missed you i've missed your voice
and i'm sure
the folks in las vegas who are used to
you entertaining us they miss you as
well but i want to get down to some
you know serious questions with you
george because a lot of people are
wondering
about las vegas and i think you're the
best person um to talk about a comeback
we survived 9 11 we survived one october
but this pandemic it's not like a
one-hit kind of thing
this will not go away do we still have
that comeback power here in las vegas
right now
i think eventually we will because las
vegas is resilient
we can stand it and we after it's over i
hope it's soon you know um
but las vegas will come back and i can't
wait to get back
i'm still uh at the west gate so i'm
still here
uh i don't have a job right now i'm
coming back i hope i get a job at the
channel eight
because god knows it's like turning bomb
there today
you gotta stop saying it's 47 degrees
outside oh it feels
[Laughter]
but george seriously have you noticed
any differences in the las vegas culture
since
9 11 and 1 october like when it comes to
giving visitors that
unparalleled experience people save up
you know
a lifetime to come here weddings happen
here it's a real
life experience las vegas is a city that
like i say resilient and then uh so many
people come there for so many different
reasons they still coming
i'm actually in atlanta now monica i'm
down in georgia in my home i left march
14th
and i can't wait to get back to las
vegas because uh
if you need some uh relaxation and you
need to laugh you need to have some fun
that's what las vegas is all about
people come to las vegas just to get
away no matter what the problem
is vegas can put a smile on your face
and that's
i can't wait to get back that's a
christmas tree right there look look at
that look at me
see vegas is all about fun i can't wait
to get back to moana amiga be
extreme and have some fun
we got football we got the raiders now
we got everything there i just can't
wait to get back
yeah and i see this video with you and
jerry seinfeld which leads me right into
my next question
what have you done let's just start
right there okay
he's been my best friend for 45 years
everybody knows i'm the real george from
scientology did you know that
alex did you know that alex
i'm his roommate for 13 years i was best
i was best man in his wedding
and i'm the father of his kids
a lot of things you guys don't know i
can't wait to get back to that rest gate
and get on that stage i don't know when
it's going to be but
we're going to bring laughter and being
a comedian that's my job is to bring
laughter you know
the best medicine in the world i know
and if we can make people laugh in las
vegas that's what it's all about
george if you had to convince folks who
are on the fence right now because
everybody you know i
i'm the kind i we quarantine if i'm not
here it's either a doctor's appointment
or something for our son but
outside of that i don't leave my home
but if you want to
my daughter came by to visit me in
atlanta the other day i lived on the
25th floor
i waved at her from the parking lot i
said keep moving
keep moving social distance and this is
as close as you're going to get
so i haven't been out ever been in a
grocery store since march 14th yeah i've
been in a bank all i do what i do now
i meet with my family here's something
you can do we meet at like drive-in
restaurants and we sit in our car
and we eat we talk to each other on the
phone and resume a lot
yeah that's one way you can meet with
your family real quick
because i have to wrap it up if you had
to convince somebody uh that it
is okay to come here to las vegas and
still enjoy yourself what would you tell
them
uh just be careful wear a mask i wear
two masks get yourself a shield
just be careful you know the protocol uh
social justice things
stay uh you know just protect yourself
be brilliant
right vigilant is that the word right
i'm all excited when i hear you monica i
get crazy and i start making up words
like like things are getting worser
worser is my new word worse
don't tell me you can't say words
producers wrapping me up george i love
you thank you so much i appreciate it
folks
i'm coming to get a job i'll be in cbs
next month i'm coming in
on monday's you can't wrap me up
okay yeah it's over there you go hey hey
nate try to jump in on that go ahead